c'est vrai que moi j'étais derrière lui
donc vous m'avez pas vu donc il était un
t-shirt noir comme ça il était mais
liquide de l'huile il avait tellement
chaud et vous vous aviez un t-shirt noir
mais vous étiez plutôt digne en fait
vous avz beaucoup moins chaud que c'est
bizarre c'était une question d'habitude
en fait c'est vrai 15 et le soir il
invite des chroniqueuses discrètement
dans les palacees parisiens pour essayer
de les PCH ouis oui j'ai des noms dis
pas non dis pas nom j'ai des noms nomasy
les de comme ça un truc comme
ça vas-y vas-y
s non c'est un level vas-y vas-y
[Applaudissements]
excuse-moi que je voulais ce que je
voulais
dire c'est pas ce que je voulais
dire non quelqu'un qui voit moins
souvent Daniel il peut truer
ici
inacible mal tout le
monde-ceit al le nom le nom du Palace a
vas-y le nom du Palace et les me une
fois que j'aurais dit le nom Le Palace
on s'en fout c'est un palace et n'oublie
pas que je suis livreur à chaque fois
que tu vas quelque part les gens
balancent partout où TER
il j' dans une bergerie dans le sud de
la France depuis un an depuis un an tous
les dégâs tous les dégâts que ça fait
depuis 10 ans Ray
transpire nom du Rachel ça dit quelque
chose Rachel Rachel
qui
attends atts attends parce que même moi
je suis pas
courors je
je c'est quoi cette histoire alorsach on
conna
aussi alors là rien mais alors je vais
dire on sait on sa attendez tu béges
tues tu bées tu
bées on laisse parler ou pas
tribun un soir on fait on fait
l'émission saz pas parce qu'il y a
longtemps c'est quoi 2018 ou 2017 avant
le covid il y a super longtemps
sémission d'ici je vais prendre un ver
prre un ver dans un grand hôel pas loin
d'où tu habites un très grand
hôtel Mo je dis pas les nom temps voil
et elle me dit il y a un bar et tout un
piano bar j'adore les pian bar dit bah
viens je te fais voir et je suis parti
là-bas BO ver les pian oui j'ad ad les
pian on est sorti 250 on jamais
[Applaudissements]
été
le me parce que toi tu pas les piano bar
moi j'adore les piano bar arrête tu bois
un ver il y a un mec qui joue du piano
tu m'avais dit les piano bar je t'en
Auris
acheté un piano et un bar et surtout de
M Rachel de souffler dans ta
[Applaudissements]
trompette tu
sors il désolé c'est du G il a tout
gaché on a bu un verre et après le
lendemain j'avais mes livraisons et je
suis parti devitêtre quoi minuit une
Conner ah tu es parti le lendemain parti
à minuit excuse-moi entre rol Garo c'est
le lutessia tu livres
quand et il travaille quand l'émission
j'en parle même pas en plus tu as loué
une chambre qui donne sur mes fenêtres
je t'ai vu non mais elle est folle cette
histoire alors après on peut sortir des
des dossiers sur tout le monde alors
vasy vasy non mais moi je suis pas comme
ça parce que si j'envoie sur les deux là
je vais tué les
detit
[Applaudissements]
truc il vou
t
[Applaudissements]
dis en fait je pense qu'il a rien mais
il bluffe rien personne le
C
pousse pas trop non plus quandême pousse
pas trop pousse pas parce que j'ai des
photos on m'voy des photos de toi des
photos de toi nu je les ai
là à la
plagevec une table une table basse et
des fauteilles en
[Applaudissements]
cuiruse
confort
la jouer contre dortm et il y a une
émission à
faire à faire là c'est quo l'istoire
c'est j'ai des photos où il regarde un
j'ai des trucs
sur si j'ai des trucs aussi vous savez
vous le savez très
bien obligé pas le dire c'est
dommage ça serait dommage que ça se
termine comme
ça ce soir on va
fa Mo j'étais à rol gar j'étais
carbonisé toute la journée vous voulez
parle on va
parlerou ceinture
j'arve fa du C à 1 he du
matin
vousz vouu jouer moi je je tout le mond
j'ai une photos j'ai text plus rien à
perdre
moiors c'est quoi cette histoire de
d non mais c'est pas une question de
hiérarchie c'est c'est tout si vous
voulez que tout pète tout pète
maintenant j'ai bu un verre c'est vrai
avec Rachel c'est vrai on arrête
là si vous voulez qu'on continue moi je
Contin j'ai mon stylo elle m'apprête un
stylo j'ai les not il a pas de problème
mais il y a une émission à faire j'ai
une énorme munition sur Raymon moi vasy
faites
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
attention
atttion fais voir fais très attention la
dernière fois je t'invite au restaurant
moi moi je t'invite au restaurant fais
très attention qu'est-ce que tu fais là
c'est quoi alors vas-y vas-y allez vasy
non mais je peux pas me moi j'ai pas fa
ah allez vous je
Jess on dit on dit la vérité on raconte
pas des conneries
je regardez voil je pensez bien fermé
votre
gueule etou fait son émission gentiment
comme tous les jours on oublie tout ça
ça aait jamais d
[Applaudissements]
avir
est calm on se
cal chacun non non non je voudrais qu'il
finiss vous vous rendez compte que on
rit on rit mais l'émission est à deux
doigs d'imploser de l'INT m' F j'en rien
à [__] moi demain j'ai mon camion je
vais c'est qui c histo de non parce
qu'il dit qu'il a des doses sur moi moi
j'ai des doses sur lui ou ou je le vois
tuas déjà balancé la plage c'esto pas la
plageire PS dortm tu déjà vu des
[Rires]
balcons qui fait un spectacle un
spectacle et derrière il y a l'écran il
y a un match de foot derrière ça te dit
rien transformiste tu mets à sur les
balconsp du fou ce
mec comment PSG Dortmund ouais Dortmund
et Barça il a organisé des si vous pas
de tout de suite je balance ça Mo rien à
c'est vous qui le chef ditesi de sauter
c'est toi qui a commencé
avectoire
ça attention j menace pas hein non mais
c'est voilà c'est rien c'est juste que
si mais sur tout le monde sur tout le
monde je peux les voir pour voir c'est
des photos ou des vidéos non c'est alors
il y a photo il y a une vidéo de envoyé
de gens que tu fréquentes de gens que tu
fréquentes que tu devrais plus
fréquenter parce que c'est des balances
il m'envoie tous les trucs derrière
regarde je balance des trucs sur toi
aussi touis oua je peux te dire moi j'ai
pas peur oh c'est des mal ça non c'est
des promesses JEE Guillaum si tu as
quelque chose à dire
disor j'ai fait 800 km ce matin c'est
pas me faire détruire tout m i c'est toi
qui a commencé c'est toi qui a
commencé en de mot en de mots
brés Brésil est vomi il m'a présenté une
brésilienne ahah oui était très
sympathique et après il m'a présenté une
deuxième fille donc il était en fait il
était en boîte de nuit rodé comme un
ignoble rat il a ramené deux filles donc
une brésilienne très sympathique et une
autre qui était sympa mais qui arrêtait
pas de vomir et donc j'anmis à galoche
les deux la même soirée alors là tu vas
retirer ça tout de suite je te le jure
parce que c'est faux et d' bien sûr que
c'est vrai ma boule totale un ignoble
rat des goû
toi c'est mer pouvez pas laisser faire
ça poszv posz vos boules
[Applaudissements]
merde
plus
[Applaudissements]
plus mais retire tout de suite là je
rigole je rigole pas c'est toi qui l'a
galoché elle elle a même après galoché
elle vomit dans ta bouche elle a vomi
chez toi
elle a vomi dans ta
boucheesign autrement on l'appelle tout
de suite qu'est-ce qu'il on l'appelle
tout de suite laomuse vomisseuse c'est
bon master sielle
vomit non mais e c'est incroyable C
sotoir ou j'en ai r surmon aussi s ah
vas-y vas-y tu étais bien
là-bas moi moi j'en ai rien à [__] je
te dis Raymon a déjà invité une
chroniqueuse à dîner dans un infam
restaurant italien es malade c'est vrai
mais il est fouel j' une choniqueuse il
a invité une chroniqueuse à dîner une
fois arrête elle a accepté elle a
accepté elle y allit ouais dans un inf
quelqu' autour de la table ouais non non
c'est Imposs non non non c'est
impossible tu dis ah non c'est pas
possible alors
vas comment tu sais qui c'est pard
oui attends j'ai invité une chroniqueuse
à manger dans un restaurant oui oui tu
lu as payé une bourata mon
salop envoie le nom mais pas croelle pas
all ça fait beaucoup là ça fait beaucoup
làelle est all envoie le nom c'est quoi
si si si les initiales la bah al la on
sait qui c'est he ou bah la bah la c'est
pas Los Angeles ouais non ah j'ai non
c'est l'avocate alors non
l'appelle j'espère pour
vous vou il voulait tout à l'heure il
voulait qu'elle VI autour de la table
attends je note vous voulez voulez
sortir r l'oire il se parl tous les deux
ils étaient très copains et un moment il
d ensem finalement ça pas fait je vous
jure c'est vrai ils ont jamais été Dîn
ensem je
dis mais
l'intentionoral as invité qui comme
fille autour de la
table AR
derertion je tire
mais alors l'abominable de ring a une
hisire avec une personnalité qui est
venue sur ce plateau il y a pas
longtempsend est blonde
il
me je dire la vérité il dit n'importe
quoi même non non il dit n'importe quoi
source S je sais que c'est fa une
influenceuse pas du tout je sais de par
je sais de qui parle et n jamais vu
cette personne en dehors du
plateau J je te jure on dirait Richard
anconinon tu m'aurais pas menti àurais
dit je leurais dit voilà voilàon déjà
vous saviez pas pour Rachel donc la tu
m'aurais pas menti à moi si non après si
vous voulez moi moi je peux jouer il des
trucs de téléréalité tout ça je peux y
aller moi pas de problème non si vous
voulez j'y vais à moi gu y parle moi moi
je peux je peux y aller sur pas le
moment de faire l'émission là
non quoi tu dis Guillaume il parle y
aller qu'est-ce que tu tu penses à quoi
Guillaume il il est beaucoup dans la
téléréalité Guillaume pas du tout orm
lui fait g connus tu vois beaucoup de
gens connus c'est quoi les sujets
aujourd'hui
là rub non il y a pas rub par qu'il a
été loin dans ce qu'il il a été loin
dans ce qu'il très loin fait de la
calomnie moi je dis des choses vraies tu
me tires dessus je te tire dessus tu
veux qu'on parle de d'une certaine Mar
arrête millionnaire pas du tout était
Jol sor
millionnaire
bra Greg millionnaire Guillaume lekine
non mais s rigol vous le saviez je j'en
ai eu écho maintenant on fait comme vous
voulez on fait l'émission que les gens
attendent
attend contre ses accusations et c'est
pas parce que Raymon a une aventure avec
Cindy
Lopez je faire c'est pas vrai pas
vra ça va beaucoup trop
loinant c'est simple on V attends
Jean-Marie t' pas ça c'est
pas Jean-Marie ça c'est pas l'Olympia
c'est pas le Stade de France ici c'est
pas les comiques là ici c'est c'est de
la dégueulasserie c'est la vraie vie
c'est de la dégueulasserie j' Mar ici je
vais faire maintenant deux colonnes je
vais écrire
jeanm non non mais je m'en fous je vais
faire c'est toi qui a commencé avec tes
histoires de d'ôel là je vais faire deux
colonnes maintenant celui qui me tire
dessus je tire pour de vrai avec des
dossiers récents je demande à C les gens
ils viennent pour voir touche pas mon
poste pas pour voir de la lessive comme
ça les G les gens apprécient beaucoup
c'est bon jeis vous dire la vérité cy
Cindy je l'adore je il l'a jamais vu en
dehors de l'émission je peux attester ce
qu'il veut toute façon merci je tu
retrouves la
raisonouve merci à tous Voilà du déb dis
ce qui est vra ce qui est faux ça c'est
fa non
je sources sont vérifé alors il m'aurait
menti ça me ferait beaucoup de peine et
margeline c'est vrai bien sûr que c'est
vrai allez on passe
s'il vous plaît en tout cas pourida
c'est
[Rires]
moi éme les vol d'avion sence beaucoup
de blessés pas
bless